how do we write the sum of three and
seven in a mathematical way the word sum
means addition and we can write this as
3 plus 7 this is an expression and as it
has only numbers in it it's called a
numerical expression only numbers
numerical expression now how do we write
the sum of a number and 7 in a
mathematical way as we don't know what
this number is we can use a variable in
its place we can write it as X plus 7
where this X can take any numerical
value as this expression also has a
variable in it it's called an algebraic
expression variables then algebraic just
numbers then numerical here's another
statement we need to write in a
mathematical way the sum of a number and
7 equals 12 this can be written as X
plus 7 is equal to 12 a number plus 7
equals 12
this is called an equation it has an
expression on each side of the equal to
sign
apart from expressions and equations the
most important concept in this topic is
that of terms look at the number 4 it is
just one term what about 4 plus X how
many terms do we have in this expression
two terms 4 and X what about the
expression 4 over X this is just one
term one term when divided by another
gives us only one term not two only plus
and minus separate the terms
multiplication and division do not so
here's the fourth example 4 plus X minus
y as we have plus and minus we can say
that this expression has three terms and
what about for X as 4 and X are
multiplied this is just one term
so remember plus and minus separate the
terms multiplication and division do not
what are like and unlike terms we will
see that in the next session